justice clarence
thomas and i didn't i didn't even know
his first name was justice but
that's pretty dope justice clarence
thomas said on monday that congress
should
suggest whether laws should be updated
to regulate social
media platforms he claims social media
platforms have come
to have unbridled control over
unprecedented amounts of speech
suggested the platform should be used as
common carriers such as trains and
telephone companies
both having large amounts of government
regulations
you know i think about this a lot
because it does
seem to me that
what used to be people just talking now
the the place where you talk
is now social media that has become the
the communication environment
and i guess people could debate and say
well no you could just talk to your
neighbors or talk to some
but you can but that's not really what
goes on anymore
you know most talking or communicating
is done now online whereas it used to be
um you had to go and
see something live there's now so much
more accessibility to
communication online most accessibility
to communication is online
and i i guess
i feel like people should be able to say
whatever they want
because it's almost like
the companies have become like the
microphone so everybody has a microphone
now and the companies have owned the
microphone
where they can't own your actual voice
but they own
the thing your voice goes through to
reach others you know
that spigot
and and yeah
it i feel like it should be regulated
somehow
you hate to have the government involved
but
at the same time because you want like
free speech but
if the way we speak is now goes through
a filter
and that filter has judgment or
jurisdiction over what is okay to say
then that seems
very dangerous
because now speech doesn't feel free it
feels very specific
like you're allowed to say things but
not these things
and i'd love to know what some of you
guys think on that you know
if you could hit the hotline
985-664-9503
um yeah you know i i just
because i feel like a lot of things yeah
they're just not allowed to be shared
and
uh not allowed to be said online things
get
labeled um things get labeled and then
taken down uh
so that just feels alarming at least let
people decide
what they want to hear or believe
but everyone should have the ability to
share i feel like
i feel like and i'm open to uh
to hear different people's thoughts on
that
because maybe also it's just our
responsibility
to be like oh well this platform isn't
uh
doesn't allow everything to be shared
and i think most people know that
but i don't know
just a lot there man there's a lot in
that little cauldron
so if you want to stir that thing hit
the hotline 985-664-9503
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one